alí hasan bacai nació en 1946 tan solo
un año antes de la partición de india y
pakistán tras su independencia de reino
unido su familia era una de las millones
de familias musulmanas que había en
india pero tras la creación de pakistán
tuvo que irse con sus abuelos de nueva
delhi dejando atrás por décadas a parte
de sus familiares por la visita india en
2014 mi madre estaba enferma en ese
momento fui a conocerla ya mi madre
después de mucho tiempo estaba postrada
en la cama la llevé al hospital y luego
tuve 15 o 16 días con ella muy bien pero
cuando me fui a la india nunca imaginé
que no la volvería a ver por bbva así
sale la división de pakistán e india
sigue presente para muchos 75 años
después debido a su gran dureza la
independencia de indias se vio en un
contexto de enfrentamiento entre los
diferentes grupos religiosos y étnicos
de esta nación una tensión que degeneró
en la ruptura del territorio en tres
partes la actual india de mayoría hindú
pakistán de mayoría musulmana y pakistán
oriental actualmente conocido como
también de mayoría musulmana
una decisión que hizo que hasta 15
millones de personas tuvieran que
desplazarse de sus hogares para llegar
al país que reconocía a su religión como
mayoritaria un desastre humanitario que
ocasionó entre 1 y 3 millones de muertos
por hambre y violencia y que separan en
la actualidad a muchas familias
hablaron
hay miles de familias así algunas
impulsadas y otras en más lugares tomar
para unirme a sus carteras sienten un
dolor intenso por la aportación y su
corazón lo soporta como nosotros
protagonistas los gobiernos de ambas
naciones deberían escuchar las quejas de
sus ciudadanos aunque un dolor difícil
de sanar ya que la mala relación actual
entre india y pakistán que se han
enfrentado en cuatro guerras el siglo
pasado ha contribuido a profundizar la
división